when it comes to finding treatments for
kovat 19 the scientific method starts
with raiding the medicine cupboard
that was how University of Oxford
researchers alighted on dexamethasone a
steroid first used in 1958 people have
tried it up and on four infections and
particularly for lung infections but
with inconclusive results and so back in
the beginning of March when we started
out
tackling code in the UK we started out
this child it was an obvious candidate I
don't think any of us had huge
expectations that it would work but what
we've seen today is really quite
impressive and compelling results many
trucks have been tried since the start
of the pandemic President Trump has
touted the benefits of
hydroxychloroquine the Oxford scientists
found that was ineffective key to their
success has been assessing every drug
with a large clinical trial an area
where the UK can genuinely claim to be
world-beating this usually came the
cheapest don't develop for years then
from novel diseases and I should have
faced something that has high
effectiveness and actually reducing
death rate from this disease and I think
that's what it will do is actually quite
outstanding so it really is a phenomenal
fame thing and I think that's something
that we have that record of a track
record off in the UK dexamethasone only
helps the sickest patients so it's far
from a cure but because it's cheap and
widely available it could have a big
impact quickly across the world matheson
is a common drug in many countries
especially in the developing countries
where it is being used for rheumatoid
arthritis for different syndrome and
also for asthma so therefore there is no
shortage of this drug in the developing
countries dexamethasone has already been
used to treat corona virus
it may be one reason why death rates in
Italy comparatively low but we didn't
know for sure it worked
until now that is a huge step forward
brother man thought Sky News